[Music]
creativity is super important in biology
because it's hugely important in the
process of evolution evolution often
takes a winding path to get to what we
see now
and if we want to follow this path in an
attempt to understand it sometimes we've
got to be as resourceful and clever as
evolution has been that requires
creativity in how we solve problems and
even creativity in the questions we ask
creativity is so important for anybody
who is thinking about who is studying
biology because the question we're
trying to understand is not just
take in all the information that we know
about biology
we want people to imagine what biology
what the natural world what the physical
world what our you know
what our bodies can actually do what our
brains can do and to be able to do that
you need to
think out of the box you need to think
about things that haven't been thought
about before and that is why biology
that is why uh creativity is so critical
for anybody studying biology
[Music]